what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
Brooklyn Nine-Nine season 4 episode 7
today ladies and Gentlemen please go
ahead and leave that like that would be
very much appreciated also be sure to uh
check us out on patreon your support
means a lot hey I got some real rejects
tease yeah go check out our our merch
store alrighty let's get to it
[Music]
who here does the best impression of
Captain Raymond Holt you will be judged
on voice body language and overall lack
of Flesh I can do a Raymond Holt what is
this glutinous monstrosity before me
this is quite sweet
what are you doing Captain hey nothing
just eating some marshmallows care for
one marshmallow
bring the squeaks
I know
good for you you won boil you won
tonight for Thanksgiving at my place
into a bathroom break times keep asking
questions about it Sergeant your slot is
after scully's hi Santiago Down Show the
toilet
my dad is coming into town and he can be
a little
tight oh Santiago's calling someone up
tight that can't be good no I'm
confident that I'll make a great first
impression on Mr Victor Santiago what'd
you do with a British accent I feel like
doing the Cuban accent would be a little
dicey for me very good call
Victor I pulled a full Amy and
researched the crap out of him he's an
ex-cop 65 years old Mary for 36 years
Cuban his favorite food flavor first
beefy dog food wait no sorry that's his
dog's favorite food his favorite food
corn
makes more sense dog food's not in the
name I know everything
I wonder who's playing the dad Edward
James Olmos I ordered a live turkey it's
being delivered because you know what
they say the yummiest turkey is the one
that just died in your hands Charles you
can't kill an animal in here that's
horrible it's disgusting we won't let
you do it right Amy it's getting late
don't make a mess
Brad says I can't rejoin the force I
don't know what I'm gonna do I guess I
could be a teacher sorry Travis the
answer is obviously istumble what did
you say to me no maybe you're wasting
your life
sorry principal Reynolds I didn't see
you there wait Travis is your son
me
me how dare you sir we will settle see
it just wouldn't work
private investigator ooh I like that
hello Mr Brando I found out where your
wife's been going and I have a seat
you're not gonna like this she's
cheating on you maybe you knew that
already you killed her and her framing
me for the murder oh gosh di license is
like two grand I can lend you the money
think of it as an investment from
someone who believes in you you carry a
checkbook with you of course you never
know when you're gonna need groceries
I could watch a whole episode of just
that did you clean your car I did but it
didn't really take so I just rented a
new one but here's the best part about a
sign especially for him using his
favorite font garamond who has a
favorite font the Santiago's do all of
them oh here he comes gotta go bike who
is it Jimmy
to finally meet you yeah look at that
you're a garamond man huh of course what
other font would I use Cambria
Papyrus didn't tell me he was so
interested in mutual funds uh yeah Amy
is so bored of hearing me talk about
allocation asset mix attribution
analysis these are just terms I throw
around all the time in alphabetical
order
full of Personality a bold personality
we know where that's code for she's a
[ __ ]
back he's in a goofy mood today how's
that uh wirefox Terrier still in the
lead in the lead the Dodge even wins a
group what oh he bet the money oh I bet
the check you gave me on the wirefox
terrier to win why would you do that but
I wanted to pay you back fast you made
it sound like the terrier was a sure
thing you said she was Majestic they're
all Majestic this is a nationally
televised dog show
we're going to pay you book your visit
and so help me God you better hope I
don't miss the in memoriam if it's dead
dogs you want to see I know where to get
my hands on dozens of them oh God
I'm gonna go get a wreath of uh do you
want something oh uh you know if they
have it maybe like a dry Riesling
excellent choice thank you
gosh in the same levels of information
on this guy yeah I didn't I brought it
with me and hid it out on the stoop so
do you have a favorite watchmaker I do
but I actually have to run to the
bathroom real quick
Christ I wonder if he's ever had a UTI
you know what I'm gonna sneak outside
and get the 4-1-1 on the UTI BRB he
loves abbreviations
totes of breathe oh no you looking for
this what oh no you must respect him
pretty cool huh I feel like Dexter I
think I never actually saw the show
billboard gave me nightmares Charles
you won't be able to go through with
this if I give this little guy a name
he's now technicolage no
Cut nikolaja's Throat sorry Gina but we
need a turkey and you're the only one
complaining I don't like it either it's
not a fair fight give the bird a gun
then see what happens
eating a big drumstick on Thanksgiving
makes Terry feel like a king sorry but
it's five against two wait you assume
Hitchcock and I want to eat that turkey
yeah thank you
get the bird on it I'll stand here and
sacrifice my life to Charles's bloodlust
I'm not gonna kill you Gina then you
already lost the apartment will run red
with the blood of nikolaj please stop
calling him that
what is that strange book you're holding
I've never seen it before Jake Peralta's
guide to tricking Amy's dead what
oh damn
I'm quite impressed you are you did a
ton of research here you made a binder
this is real Santiago stuff
I was wondering what you thought about
one of my cases first Essex Bank Heist
yes I read that one they got robbed the
day before they're grand opening I never
saw that one that bothered me for 20
years team up he had an alibi the name
of the company was Russo and Sons so I
figured probably maybe definitely the
Suns did it oh my God the sun's I think
you might be on this song really I don't
know how I missed that I bet they still
live here in New York we should go talk
to them right now
hell man looks like the lion is Gonna
Roar again
and the Barracuda is gonna what
[Laughter]
Jimmy Smits was third season Dexter main
guester money's already in the Caribbean
there's nothing I can do looks like
we're going to the Caribbean
[Music]
you do know we're not going to the
Caribbean right I didn't know that that
is a bummer
oh
this ends now I am so sorry girl great
party
out the window oh no don't drop the
flightless bird
why is he looking at me like that
and those Talons are super sharp huh I
think it's a freaking dinosaur
s
your stuns were back in Brooklyn robbing
the bank but we were at the softball
tournaments you also have a framed
photograph of the team a videotape of
the whole event
a newspaper article about it and
security footage
my brother and I had to gather all that
information 20 years ago when we got
accused of the exact same stuff by him
say what now oh what
the beagle's been eliminated our dog is
in the top three
[Music]
put the dog show on it once the game's
on at once what are the dogs
I think I know what's happening here
you're upset because Amy and I have seen
each other's butts what oh god it wasn't
that oh but you know I don't like you
Jake is my binder apparently no
because of my binder well you think I
wouldn't do my own research find out
everything I could about whoever my
daughter is dating oh my God I don't
want my only daughter dating a screw-up
yeah well I don't want my only
girlfriend daughtering a jerk dad burn
on you
[Music]
so feel free to tell me all about your
sexuality
[Music]
I can't date someone unless I have my
father's approval oh obviously you can
you guys act like this is your decision
to make like the woman doesn't even
exist in this equation well this woman
wait Amy shut up excuse me no you were
making a totally valid point about
gender equality but I just thought of
something really important so I'm gonna
hang up on you okay love you bye
it wasn't Russo or his sons
it was the daughter
consequences for my actions enough I
started this
I'm gonna end it
yes
Bichon frize dismissed we're the top two
just us on that stupid freaking
Schnauzer come on wirefox Terriers
the judges made the decision shut up
Shut Up Hold My Hand Captain hold my
hand come on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm just gonna chop the heck out of this
bastard but then he looked me in the eye
and I realized
nature is beautiful he scratched you up
real bad dude yup he got me good no ow
we realized we never checked the
daughter's Alibi she wasn't at the
softball trip she had access to the
plants and then she just confessed
that's right we arrested a woman today
because we are feminists
it only matters what Amy thinks and
apparently she loves you I do
oh it's the first time we've ever kissed
yeah
I just won 70 grand so Rosa pack your
bags we're going to Tampa type can't
wait guys I'm out of Cuda
oh no they're all dead the next episode
has a whole new cast
wow that was a really wacky episode that
was really wacky yeah man super super
wackadoodle do I had fun with that one
though man it got really funny it was
really creative
the hijinks ensued in a really creative
way that I thoroughly
enjoyed because in the first parts of it
it was like this feels very much like
sitcom writing and then like the jokes
did
but then uh once they all got to the
Thanksgiving dinner and and then
especially when
it was really when the dad uh Jimmy
Smith had found the um
the binder yeah because it just felt
like if it's like so it was so wacky and
so sketch heavy and so many like
different like it was so uh
escalated and uh High concept throughout
with so much just like chopping off the
turkey and [ __ ] oh yeah and then placing
the bed on the dog and then there's some
meta jokes with like pimentos here and
stuff um but then and and and and like
uh Holt this episode was very kind of
goofy he was much goofier than usual
um but yeah once once the [ __ ] started
all like
plummet you know with the dot the place
in the bat and then uh Jimmy Smith's
finding the binder uh and then I thought
it was like really clever when the
turkey got like it all just turned
against them the turkey got loose you
know I I thought that was really really
funny wrap around and yeah it's true
this is a classic classic story of like
my daughter shouldn't date this person
and I want to look for approval and as a
guy I wasn't even thinking watching this
episode
what's Amy's opinion on this I I was
under the impression Amy would want
I heard the ads approval that's right my
mind was at I was like oh yeah that's
true I never ran this buyer yeah yeah
that's solid it's a solid thing and I'm
watching this like I even I'm
conditioned to to think that way often
times so yeah yeah
right
how are you I'm great so I had a blast
with this episode as well and yeah I
mean it is uh boisterous and wacky but
it still had even though like
Thanksgiving isn't really the point uh
you know it still felt kind of like a
nice holiday episode to get everybody
out of the precinct like I thought they
did a clever job of incorporating some
kind of police situation and just using
that for both character stuff but also
you know like a fun Touchstone for what
the show is about and yeah I like the
mislead of them just getting along
famously at first and you're like oh man
you know like I wasn't thinking about
the other shoe dropping it's like you
know there's gotta be something it can't
just be that it's working out well but
it the whole start of it with Jake and
him meeting at the airport and like oh
is that the font you know like I really
bought that they were really hitting it
off and then when it comes down to the
pride of oh you think you you have the
obvious answer to my case I'm gonna take
you here and embarrass you about it it's
not like yeah the way that that story
played out was both really fun but also
very endearing and then the ultimate
conclusion was engaged in a very nice
way it transcended like it knew when to
use Whimsy and and like you said sketch
you know very sketch sensibility but
then it also knew when to you know zero
in on the actual story and the actual
themes at hand and uh and yeah like as
wacky and silly as it is to have the the
rest of the gang like cornered by this
turkey I thought that turned into a
pretty amusing sequence of bits and then
yeah to kind of isolate these two pairs
Jimmy Smits and and Jake uh Mr Santiago
and Jake and then pimento and Holt I
thought those were two like really fun
Pairs and you had to get you know you're
you're heavy like I might have maybe
wanted to see a little bit more of Jimmy
Smith's and uh and Amy together
um but yeah like I thought the pair of
him and Jake worked really well I
thought the pair of pimento and whole
like there's such polar opposite
characters but having Holt in a morse
silly fashion this episode and in a more
sort of um yeah just sort of uh letting
loose more uh made for a nice compliment
to pimento because obviously Holt is is
way more straight laced but you know
their their frequencies harmonized in a
way I thought was really fun and the
whole you know hijinks of them having to
go out and find the money and and then
getting everybody at the bar in on uh
the dog show yeah just like all these
all these things amounted to something
that was like fun and wacky but also
like really endearing kind of across the
board and uh yeah I thought all those
flavors made for sort of a nice kind of
Thanksgiving hijinks flavor so uh yeah
good stuff man good stuff all around
all right guys well thanks for being
here I hope you guys all have a good
Thanksgiving yeah and um hey let's send
this for the patreon
Mark Leach mark my friend um it's been a
crazy time for you as of late and I
wanted to say first off thank you for
being with us through so much and thank
you for being a part of our lives
and thank you for being you you've been
very open and honest and um very
vulnerable as of late and I know that
when certain experiences happen and
during the holidays they can actually be
even tougher so I'm sorry that certain
things have occurred during this time
however you know like as we were talking
recently
there's things to remember and reminisce
on that I I I was I found quite
beautiful and profound in the way you
were talking to me about things that I
think there's a lot to still be thankful
for and I think there's plenty of people
out there to be thankful for obviously
going around in your life and and I
would
I'll make the concerted effort to go out
there and bond with people during this
holiday season I know in the UK they
don't really celebrate Thanksgiving
because there's no point
but out here yes it is a timed uh it's
time to remember to be grateful for some
things and and I I would say that I'm
grateful for you and I I think during
this time it's
hold on to some of those memories we're
talking about and and simultaneously
look around for what to be grateful for
in your present and it'll make life
not perfect but it'll make it a little
bit better so
yeah buddy
just keep being honest keep being
vulnerable and
find where you can genuinely look at and
just go you know what I'm grateful for
that even if it is something very
minuscule it'll it'll it'll help it all
all compounds and it's something
positive eventually
so yeah yeah be well brother
thank you